this is a production of cornell
university
thank you very much for your
introduction dr butler and thank you for
the opportunity today
to describe some of our adventures of
using molecular tools
at the corvallis gene bank
much of what we do at the repository is
the result of
collaborations that are wide
they involve our team at the national
clonal germplasm repository in corvallis
with our curators kim hammer and joseph
postman
and a group of um
jason zearn and jill buchakra
who are who were postdocs with us
visiting scientist k
dale kim
many students and technicians
uh we collaborate with many
of our colleagues with the usdars at the
4hc
and serial research facility john
henning who's a
breeder hub reader
at the horticultural crop research unit
chad finn
who
laid chad finn who is a small food
breeder
jungman lee
[Music]
who conducts fruit analysis
richard bell generally from the
appalachian fruit lab
uh breeder and pathologist lisa roland
from the genetic improvement for fruits
and vegetables
bc berry cultivar development michael
dossett who did his masters and phd in
corvallis
the
donald danforth plant science center
todd muchler and doc
bryant who worked with us on developing
the black raspberry genome
and many collaborators at universities
like the university of florida
vance whitaker sangili and paul irene
oregon state university kelly weining
christina mulch who's a student now and
phylogenomist aaron liston
north carolina state university hamid
ashjafi rishi arial massimo yoritzo who
leads the
vaccap scri funded project uc davis
sarah montanari david neal and michael
hartigan and larry alice at western
kentucky university this list is
definitely not um
comprehensive and i really hope i'm not
forgetting anyone i'm just try i just
try to list the people who contributed
to the work i'm describing today
the corvallis repository is one of eight
clonal repositories in the national
planned germplasm system and it's where
this red dot is in oregon
our federal facilities and most of our
farm are located on oregon state
university ground which is located
within the traditional homelands
of the mary's river or ampinifu band of
calapuya
following the willamette valley treaty
of 1855
the kalapuya people were forcibly
removed to reservations in western
oregon
where their descendants now reside
and we'd like we are very grateful for
their um
sacrifice
currently
our um
our collection
contains about 13 000 accessions from 73
genera
that consists of
mostly eight major genera and their wild
relatives
we are
responsible for preserving
hazelnut corals
strawberry frageria
hops humulus
mint
pear
currants and gooseberries
blackberries and raspberries and
blueberries and
cranberries and our collections range in
size from about 500 in mint to over 2300
in pair
we are very very passionate
about our mission of supporting
agricultural production
by acquiring conserving
evaluating and characterizing
documenting and freely distributing our
germ plasm
as i said our
crops are clonally propagated
and our primary collections of non-tree
fruits
are preserved maintained in screen
houses to protect them from
insect vectored viruses you see here the
frageria collection on the left and the
rubus collection on the right you see
they are maintained in pots in screen
houses
and they are not allowed to flower or
fruit to maintain their genetic
integrity and as you can see here
they're really difficult to distinguish
morphologically
and to keep them in a vigorous state and
able to produce the propagules we
distribute they are propagated on a
cycle
depending on the genus three six or ten
year cycles
which is a process that is error prone
and our three collections the pear and
hazelnuts
are maintained in orchards in the field
and a subset of our blueberry collection
is also maintained in the field in
addition to this greenhouse as dr
buckler mentioned the molecular lab was
established in september 2002 when i was
hired
now that i've given you a little bit of
a background on the germplasm repository
i thought today that i would like to
give you
a little bit of examples on how
characterizing genetic resources at the
repository at the repository
allowed us to confirm identity
reconstruct pedigree
establish a core
determine phylogenetic relationship
validate associations of markers with
important traits and provided
opportunities for genome-wide
association studies
we've been able to identify genomic
regions associated with important traits
and i wanted to
tell you is one of my favorite stories
that covers acquiring germplasm all the
way to using it
and
developing cultivars that meet the
industry needs
and end with current approaches of
dna characterization right now what
we're thinking
so starting with examples of identity
confirmation
as i said our blueberry collection is in
the field and in screen houses the field
collection we see the fruits and that
enables us to do
phenotype the fruits and host
open houses for the public so they can
enjoy the diversity of the blueberry
collection and then our screen house
collection is the one
that we use for um for
getting propagules and and distributing
uh from our accession so it's very
important for us
um to
to assess whether
the
the plants four or five plants
representing each of these accessions
are the same genotype
as we've done for
most of our
major genera we've developed a
multiplexed fingerprinting sets of
long core repeat simple sequence repeats
in blueberry it's made up of 10 ssrs
as you can see here in pioneer
blueberry
so in this study um we
genotyped with this fingerprinting set
over 360 plants representing 100 the
most
requested
accessions 140 accessions
they were mostly from the germplasm
repository and we also included some of
the cultivars
that we obtained from the
breeders that allowed us to
we use parentage analysis to confirm
identity
and we propose the following ontology to
categorize these accessions
so true to type is where
um the
parentage analysis
confirmed
that these accessions are true to type
identity okay where we had
allele composition for only one of the
parents and it agreed and the morphology
of the plant agreed with the cultivar
but we'd like more information to move
it to true to type
we've had some that our identity in
question
where the allele composition did not
match the reported parentage and wrong
identity where
the morphology and the allele
compositions did not agree and the
plants were discarded so right now we
have a student that is working on
resolving the idq and id question
issues in blueberry and replacing these
accessions with true to type accessions
one of the
accessions that we were able to
determine as true to type through
parentage analysis is florida 4b
according to breeder paul irene
almost all southern high bush cultivars
trace back to this single clone florida
4b that was collected in 1949 by ralph
sharp at winterhaven florida
so we had two genotypes for florida 4b
1790 and florida 4b the other florida 4b
and um
through parentage analysis you can see
here that the 1790 contributed its
alleles 180 and 231 at these two ssrs to
the offspring us-75
confirming that
it is the
the reported florida 4b
and population structure analysis
uh collections of vaccinium eliot eye
vaccinium foscatum and vaccinium duraway
that were collected in florida
and included this florida 4b accession
1790 uh identified it as a hybrid
between vaccinium darwin and vaccinium
foscatum that are being used in breeding
high bush blueberry
another story of confirming identity is
that of the poison berry that you might
have heard of
boysenberry was developed in the
1920s by rudolf boyzen a hobbyist
breeder here you can see his wife
grandma peggy
eating boysenberry
and we obtained this
picture of her from her granddaughter
janet boyzen fitzgerald
so at the time before the study we did
not know the pedigree of boysenberry but
it was believed to be the result of a
cross between logan
and an unknown trailing blackberry
um
variants of boys and believed to be
sports have been industry standards
during their various points in history
the three most important ones were
poison 43
that's been in oregon in the sea strand
standard in the 1990s and believed to be
used in the breeding program of the
usdars in corvallis oregon another
another variant is riwaka's choice that
was selected in new zealand and nectar
bearing so in this study we used our
blackberry fingerprinting set
to genotype
accessions
of boysenberry and their variants and
potential parents we obtained them from
four nurseries three private farms
including that of janet boyes and
fitzgerald the granddaughter of rudolph
boyzen who developed it from the
national clean plant network
and from the usdars breeding program in
corvallis and the repository
as you can see we ended up with five
different genotypes of boysenberry
that are different
um
we were using parentage analysis we were
able to determine that
this boysenberry here from uh the
private farm of janet boyce and
fitzgerald
that match that of thornless poison from
a nursery and another boysenberry from
um another private farm in california
appeared to be the result of logan by
austin mays
and clonal variants that were believed
to be clonal variants are actually
offspring of boysenberry
and multiple genotypes are being sold by
nurseries under boysenberry you can see
here the same nursery where the red
arrow is the same
nectar boysenberry obtained in 2012 and
2018 had totally different fingerprints
so
different genotypes are being sold under
the same name for boysenberry
another uh
another project the east coast hops
project was established in 2012
at the university of as a collaboration
between the unis university of maryland
and a flying dog brewery
and it's led by brian butler an
extension agent
following an article in the smithsonian
describing this collaboration
to identify hop
uh accessions or cultivars
that are suitable for
the mid-atlantic region and that can be
used to brew local
local beer
some
farmers or
local people
gave brian butler
accessions that do well and that are
believed to have been there for over a
hundred years in that region
and brian butler was desperate to know
what
whether these
accessions are unique
so we were in the process of using our
hop fingerprinting set to genotype all
of our collection as well
uh as a few hundred accessions from the
breeding program of john henning in
corvallis
and we were able to determine that
unknown one
that
matched that of centennial
uh cultivar was bred in 1974 and
released by washington state university
in 1990
while the second unknown
um you can't read this but
the gray
here
is unknown to
it grouped with wild north american
accessions and appears to be
unique
and university of maryland owns the
rights to it and plans to release it to
brew local beer
moving on to stories of pedigree
reconstruction i start with a story of
old one by farmingdale rootstocks that
are still being used at rootstocks
currently
old home and farming in farmingdale are
two very fire blight resistant pear
cultivars that professor frank reimer
from oregon state university obtained in
1915
from
benjamin buckman in farmingdale illinois
old home has worthless fruit but is
graft compatible with quince
and professor frank reimer
found it to be
very useful for producing blight
resistant
offspring
particularly with the farmingdale
and at the time farmingdale was thought
to be a seedling of anjou one of the
more light resistant european cultivars
in 2000 the repository
maintains 41 of these
old home by farmingdale selections
uh the ones that we maintain are ones
that were
released
in the later 1990s a lot of studies were
done
on a collection of seedlings that
brook lyle in 1952 obtained from frank
reimer from an old home orchard
that had farmingdale as a pollinizer so
about half kilo gram of seeds were
obtained
and these were further
evaluated
and for rootstock desirable traits such
as ability to propagate from hardwood
cuttings
fire blight resistant most importantly
and then sizing
so in 2009 when we
when we genotyped six of these old home
by farmingdale
clones we found that farmingdale could
not be the parent of these old home by
farmingdale rootstocks but bartlett is
and then anjou
is likely the the parent
of farmingdale
and
um these findings were
confirmed using
snip data that was developed in 2020
for all 40
selections the majority
were the result of a cross between old
home by bartlett except for two that
were the result of a claw cross between
old home by anjou
um
so uh in 2019 2020
um sarah montaneri who was at uc davis
at the time led the development of a 70k
snip array for pair
and we used it to
evaluate um
evaluate over 1600 accepted genotype
over 1600 accessions from the repository
and we found only 11 13 of them had a
unique genotype
and 534 of the trees belong to a
208 sets of duplicates 54 of which were
previously unknown
right now we are looking to evaluate
them phenotypically particularly for
fruit traits to confirm
that they are actually duplicates and
there was no error in sampling or
genotyping
the study allowed us to reconstruct
pedigree
from 139
3 years and confirm their pedigree
but
498
were newly identified we didn't know
about
at all i only talk about
white dwayne that originated in 1652
and is
is a very important founder it's parent
of 56 accessions including
the uh most commonly planted
bartlett or william boncretian and also
anjou two of the very important
cultivars currently being grown
bartlett
uh that is found in berkshire in
1770
it has been heavily used in breeding in
its parent of 156 of the accessions that
were included in that study including
club favorite and kefir a hybrid between
european and asian pear
the late chad finn um
ever since we developed fingerprinting
sets for a lot many of our crops like
blackberry here
we started
confirming parentage of his releases
and eclipse is one of the
cultivars that he released
it's a semi-erect
semi-erect blackberry with uniform dark
fruits
and it ripens in relatively early in the
semi-erect
season
it was selected in 2004 from a cross
made in 2001 and it was believed to be
the result of a cross between a
selection or auras 1393-1
and triple crown
when we did parentage analysis on
eclipse we found that it cannot it had a
leaves that were not present in either
of these
parents
so then chad and his technician
mary looked through the records and
uh found a note about the possibility of
another selection or is 1392-1
being a parent
so
1392-1 is not available anymore but the
repository has
its parents ena hardy and chester thomas
and when these were used in pantage
analysis we found that sure enough
1392-1
by triple crown are the actual parents
of eclipse
moving on to establishing core
collections
um it's a concept that was introduced in
the late 1980s to increase the
efficiency of characterization and
utilization of collections stored in
gene banks
while preserving as much as possible of
the diversity of the entire collection
so core collections have been formed for
each of our major
genera
based on key morphological traits
and
geographical origin of the cultivar
releases
and
these
core collections were formed in a
collaborative effort between the curator
of each collection
and the corresponding crop germplasm
committee
in strawberry 323
of the cultivated strawberry frageria
ananasa
make up the core collection
in 2013
odong described
different types of core collections
cci that represents the diversity of the
collection
ccx that represents the extremes
in the collection extremes of the trait
and then ccd
that
represents the distribution of the
accessions
in the collection and he
developed quality criteria for making
sure
these collections uh so for being able
to assess the quality of these
collection core collections
so using snip data of our entire
fragaria ananasa cultivated
strawberry collection of 539 accessions
that were generated
from genotyping with the 35k array
that we developed and the 50k array
developed by stevenapps group
we were able to develop a ccx
core
and cci core
using a seed
13 accessions that we determined uh as
positive and negative controls for some
of the dna tests we were we applied to
them so
jointly
the cci ccx
178 accessions from these two cores
are way less than the 323
core that was determined uh using
morphological traits and locality data
and that enables us to
to
more efficiently
conserve our resources and being able to
propagate 178
accessions for characterizing is a lot
easier than propagating 323 accessions
germplasm repositories are ideal for
phylogenetic analysis as they hold the
domesticated
species as well as their wild relatives
and in fragaria we have a large
collection of frageria ananasa the
the octoploid
cultivated strawberry as well as most of
its
relatives that are deployed tetraploid
as hexaploid you have one hexaploid and
decouploid
so um
in this study we um sequenced
chloroplasts and used them
to for phylogenetic analysis
um
and
here we illustrate bayesian
relationships of these chloroplast
sequences
you can see that it resolved them into
two well supported clay a and c
and also based on runnering into
monopodial and sympodial runnering
mostly
and then
in claddy a within clade a you can see
that
vesca is not bonophyletic frageria vesta
is a diploid
strawberry is not monophyletic here you
can see the americana vesca subspecies
americana as well as the uh
subspecies vascular
and
subspecies bracthriata that
that is native
uh to the cascades to the pacific
and the
cascade ranges of north america from
british columbia to california
is closely related to the
uh octoploid progenitors of frageria ana
nasa fragaria virginia and fragaria
chilowances and to the native
uh hybrid between those two
as well as to the decaploidy true
pencils
and frageria vesca subspecies bracteata
then is the donor of the chloroplast
genome to the octopoid clade
um
another study uh
of phylogeny using mostly accessions
from the repository is that of rubus
lubus is a very complex genus that
contains over 500 species
and in the early 1900s folk
classified it or divide
divided it into 12 subgeneral
in
1999 there was a phylogeny phylogenetic
analysis by larry alice who collaborated
on this work here
using its regions
and so in this study
we use target capture
of
about a thousand single copy genes
uh of rubus
and chloroplast uh sequences for
phylogenetic analysis
and
all the different phallogenetic analysis
um
agreed on
grouping on on eight groups
uh of these accessions that that are
representatives of all 12
subgenera
the only monophyletic subgenera were
aurobatas
here
and
ano clobatus in clay 2
and rubus was mostly
monophyletic
but uh rubus is the subgenus that has
all the blackberries it giovaris has the
raspberries and is polyphylactic and has
members in five different clades
plate five contains closely related
asian polyploid species from five
different
uh subgenera
so subgeneric classifications do not
reflect phylogenetic relationships and
need further work
the
accessions at the repository where
phenotypic
data is available are
ideal for
validating
markers associated with those traits
and
supported by the
scri-funded rosby project
we were able to validate some of these
dna tests for perpetual flowering here
and then um
fruit quality traits like
gamma decalactone and mesofuran here
and then for disease
resistance traits
like
crown rot
uh bacterial spot
and then anthracnose resistance and we
were able to establish
accessions that are positive and
negative controls for these dna tests
all of this is described in a dna
testing handbook that we've established
in 2019 and updated in 2021
in collaboration with sangee lee and
vance whitaker's group at
university of florida so this dna
testing handbook is available
on the genome database for the rosaceae
website and then all of these accessions
positive and negative controls are
available from the repository
moving on to pair with funding from the
again rose breed
we
were able to
to identify
chromosome 2
a chromosome 2 region
as controlling fire blight resistance in
three families that were developed in by
the breeder in kearneysville usd ars in
kernersville from three different
sources old home potomac and an nj
accession so this chromosome 2 region
was also previously found to control
fire blight resistance
we went on
further to sequence the genes
in this region from resistant and
susceptible parents and some progeny
and identified bases that are associated
with
resistance particularly in
disease resistance genes
we are right now in the process of using
six snip
to uh confirm association
um of these
bases
by genotyping them
in accessions that are known to be
resistant
and susceptible
from the repository and
also from colleagues in kernersville and
in new zealand and our objective here is
to develop easy and cost-effective dna
tests that can predict
fire blight
resistance
as i said having a collection in the
field and being able to observe the
fruit fruits
provide opportunities for genome-wide
associations and we are
using that in blueberry we're
phenotyping them
for food texture traits and
collaboration uh with massimo yorito who
leads the va cap
and fruit quality traits too in
collaboration again with massimo as well
as
astrophys group and also for
bioavailability
some of these were genotyped with the
30k target capture
from rapid genomics and
they will also be genotyped where the
20k
target capture
uh platform that we are developing in
the vaccap i'm in charge of developing
this uh 20k
flex seeking exl platform
and my favorite story of acquiring
germplasm to
using them in breeding
so the challenge for the black raspberry
industry has been
that black raspberry plants die three to
four years after planting them
due to a black raspberry necrosis virus
complex that is vectored by the
north american large raspberry aphid
so um
michael dossett was a
master's student at the time
uh he and
chad finn and the curator kim hummer for
black
raspberry they themselves collected and
obtained seed from 27
u.s states and two canadian provinces
that are in the native range of
black raspberry
they subsequently germinated these
seedlings and screed them for screen
them for aphid resistance in 2007 and
2008
and identified three
sources of resistance one from ontario
canada one from michigan and one from
maine
they then subsequently established three
populations and determined
that a single gene
uh is responsible for each of the three
sources
funding from the specialty crop research
initiative allowed us
to map these three sources to three
separate but linked loci on rubus
linkage group six
and to identify one marker
hrm or
high resolution melting or simple
sequence repeat that identify
resistance irrespective of the source we
now routinely use this hrm marker to
screen
seedlings each year for resistance or
susceptibility and only the resistant
seedlings are planted in the field and
evaluated further for other traits
and we are collaborating with christina
mulch who is a master's student and
kelly weining
on using differential expression
profiling of resistant versus
susceptible
seedlings pre and 12 hours post
inoculation with aphid for each of these
three different sources
for three different for three new
populations
to find a map to identify the candidates
that are
associated with resistance and then
subsequently
uh
map
saturate
rubus-lingus group six
and develop markers that are specific
for each of these sources of resistance
so that we can permit
these sources and use use
um and ensure durable resistance
so um
our current approach to molecular
characterization at the corvallis gene
bank consists of collaborating
with anybody who would like to
collaborate with us
we're thinking that for identity
confirmation given that we've developed
fingerprinting sets and we have existing
databases
we'll continue using
ssr based fingerprinting sets when we
have a qui a question
for a small number of accessions
we are also um developing casp assays
for
some of our crops we have one for hop
we
have started one for blueberry and red
raspberry so when we have a large number
of samples to assay we think it's more
economical to use casp
and now that breeding insect is
developing dart tag in blueberry and
strawberry would like to
test dart tag for
different studies
where we need a medium number of markers
for g wise we like to collaborate for
our field collections we like to
collaborate on phenotyping our
collections
and then for our screenhouse and
greenhouse collections we're always
happy to propagate and collaborate on
phenotyping and genotyping what we have
in the collection
and then i'd like to leave you with a
take-home message of
molecular characterization of genetic
resources is really a collaborative
effort that requires different
expertises
and then the ncgr diverse collections
provide
many many opportunities for many
different studies
our long core ssr fingerprinting sets
are available for most of our crops and
they are quite useful for identity
confirmation for uh
you know small number of samples mostly
and then the snip platforms are cost
effective
when dealing with a large number of
samples in multiples of 96
we believe that casp assays are economic
and fast and they're becoming available
in our crops
and we'd like to continue
collaborating on
genomic association studies
and we welcome collaborations on on
these
and i'd like to acknowledge funding from
many different sources and they include
specialty crop research initiative nifa
grants rose breed vaccap and one for
black raspberry
the national plant germplasm system
evaluation grants
and many different organizations
like the california pear advisory board
brewers association northwest center for
small fruit research
oregon raspberries and blackberries
western kentucky university narba the
washington tree fruit research
commission of course our chris
and thank you so much for your attention
and
welcome your questions
about five minutes or so for questions
has the rate of collection and addition
of germplasm to the repository
uh continue to increase or is there a
trade-off with the molecular
characterization you have to do
no it it continues to increase
slowly you know there are countries from
which we cannot get accessions and then
of course we haven't had explorations
the last two years because of covet but
they do continue to increase
and really the molecular lab is
you know it's only me and right now one
technician we don't have uh
it's three scientists at the repository
two curators and me
so
i thought the your pedigree validation
was really excellent to see the
proportions where people were getting
things right
and everything but you had that identity
okay
at 54
um
how many of those do you think are going
to validate out either being truly fully
correct
or with more investigation you're gonna
you know
they only got one parent right you know
the father one yes
you know i think the majority will be
right because also um
you know we have breeders that come and
look at the phenotype
and compare it to what is in the
literature
and they say it mostly fits
so we don't want to put them as true to
type yet until we confirm through
pedigree analysis whether
yeah whether they are true to type
so we have one from the chat from connor
how do you see the bioinformatics
techniques for this kind of work
developing or changing in the future
well we really really need
bioinformatics support and
we've had some over the years right now
we don't have any
um i had a bioinformaticist who just
went on to do um
her phd right now but we'll be seeking
right now we're advertising for a
postdoc who would have some
bioinformatic
support
yeah definitely
we need bioinformatics
so now one other question you know on
the release
uh the clips released from uh from chad
how frequently do you think the
varieties we actually release actually
have their pedigree messed up
you know i oh
so uh
this is something we only started the
last few years with chad
and um
out of the
i would say
maybe six or so that we
evaluated only one was messed up so
yeah so you have to have higher numbers
to give a percent i cannot give a person
right
i was wondering if there's some kind of
jackpot things that actually the ones we
release
you know sometimes you're making more
mistakes than everything else but
i can't say that
okay great thank you
you're welcome
okay so we've got a couple more in the
chat here just comments for apples there
are a few well-known cultivars that were
mis identified in the germplasm
collection
these are now being sold by the nursery
industry which further complicates the
situation is there a similar situation
for the crops you work with and if so
how have you dealt with the situation
with the nursery industry that's from
greg tech
yes uh we see that um you know in
blueberry as you saw there were 13 15
percent misidentified in strawberry
we're finding about 20 percent
misidentified
now with regards to nurseries um
we've tested in
some in black raspberry
we've tested as you saw in boysenberry
and you have different names different
genotypes
um or the same name for different
genotypes so
um that is com it looks like it it
shouldn't say
common it does happen
um we
present at a commission we we present
our findings and we talk to nurseries
about it
but um
that's the extent to which we do that
but we want to ensure that what we have
is true to type and is confirmed as true
to type
yeah
we have another um question from geneva
she and
excellent talk nyla
appreciated seeing the diversity of
species you are working on do you notice
some species that have higher rates of
somaclonal variation than others
you know i noticed some accessions
having a high high rate you know like
bartlett we have a lot of bartlett
clones and so in pair we have bartlett
clones we have um
what else i'm trying to think of other
examples
um
i think it's it's a genotype specific
moira also in blueberry we've found some
uh blueberry accessions that are prone
to soma clonal variation in tissue
culture
one of them uh
i know we genotyped for a nursery and
were able to detect the variation and
they stopped selling that i don't want
to say which cultivar that is but we've
seen that
more
i think it's more uh cultivar specific
or accession specific
uh any other questions
naila it's been fantastic having you
thank you so very much for your time we
really appreciate it
thank you it's a pleasure to talk to you
thank you very much
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu